هذا وننقل عن مراسل الجزيره هذا الخبر قصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي يستهدف محيط بلده كفر شوبا
جنوبي لبنان كذلك افاد مراسل الجزيره
باطلاق صاروخين من جنوب لبنان باتجاه موقع
رويسات العلم الاسرائيلي في تلال فر شوبه
المحتله وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي نفذت سلسله غارات على
بلده عيت الشعب في القطاع الاوسط من جنوب
لبنان كما استهدفت مسيره اسرائيليه بصاروخ
سياره في بلده خربه سلم وافاد مراسلنا
بتعرض بلده العديسه ومحيط بلده الخيام
لقصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي وكذلك اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
استهداف سلاح الجو بنيه تحتيه ومواقع
عسكريه لحزب الله واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
كذلك رصده عمليه اطلاق قذيفه مضاده للدروع
نحو مدينه كريات
شمونه معنا الان من مرجع يون جنوب لبنان
مراسلنا جوني طانيوس ومن الجليل الاعلى
مراسلتنا فاطمه خمايسي اهلا بكم جوني
وفاطمه ابدا معك جوني اذا ضعنا في صوره
المستجدات عندك وتفاصيل ما ذكرناه من
انباء كما ذكرت ليلى هناك سلسله من
المعطيات الميدانيه التي يمكن التوقف
عندها بشان الاوضاع هنا في هذه المناطق
الحدوديه اخرها واحدثها القصف المدفعي
الاسرائلي بعدد من القذائف على محيط بلده
كفرشوبا التي تقع خلفنا وذلك في اعقاب
اطلاق صاروخين من الاراضي اللبنانيه
باتجاه موقع رويسات العلم ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يعلن حزب الله مسؤوليته عن هذه
العمليه بالاضافه الى سلسله ايضا من
المعطيات الاخرى والغارات الاسرائيليه
والحوادث الميدانيه هنا في هذه المناطق
الحدوديه ما هو لافت ايضا هذه الغاره التي
نفذتها مسيره اسرائيليه على احدى السيارات
في بلده خربه سلم وبحسب المعطيات
والمعلومات هناك ضحايا جراء هذه الغاره
ايضا بانتظار مزيد من التفاصيل ومزيد من
المعطيات عن الجهات عنيه الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه كانت بدات صباحا بغارات جويه
شنتها المقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على
بلده عيتا الشعب في القطاع الاوسط
بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعي بالقذائف الحارقه
والدخان على عده بلدات هنا في القطاع
الشرقي ابرزها بلده الخيام وبلده كفر كلا
حتى هذه اللحظه كما ذكرنا حزب الله لم
يعلن عن تنفيذه اي عمليه عسكريه بشكل رسمي
يوم امس كان حزب الله اعلن عن تنفيذه عشر
عمليات باتجاه مواقع مختلفه باتجاه تجمعات
للجنود الاسرائيليين ومراكز عسكريه وواضح
ان الحزب يواصل نهجه ويواصل سياسته لناحيه
تكثيف العمليات باتجاه المواقع العسكريه
الاسرائيليه ومحاوله الحاق اكبر ضرر ممكن
بالقوات الاسرائيليه المنتشره قباله
الحدود الجنوبيه اللبنانيه تضامنا مع قطاع
غزه كما يعلن بشكل دائم حزب الله هناك
طبعا ترقب لمسار الامور هنا في هذه
المناطق الحدوديه في ضوء التصريحات
الاخيره لمسؤولين من حزب الله تحديدا عن
مساله الرد على اغتيال صالح العاروري في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت يوم امس قال رئيس
المجلس التنفيذي في الحزب هاشم صفي الدين
ان استهداف مركز القياده والمراقبه الجويه
في جبل ميرون يوم السبت ب 62 صاروخا هو
جزء من الرد على عمليه الاغتيال وستكون
هناك ردود اخرى بالاضافه ايضا الى تصريحات
اخرى سجلتها الساعات الماضيه ابرزها لرئيس
كتله حزب الله في البرلمان اللبناني الذي
اشار الى ان اي امر يتعلق بالاوضاع في هذه
المناطق الحدوديه لا يمكن البحث فيه
والتطرق اليه قبل وقف اطلاق النار في قطاع
غزه وبالتالي هي سلسله من السياقات
السياسيه
والميدانيه المترابطه بشان الاوضاع هنا في
جنوب ب لبنان ربطا بما يجري في قطاع غزه
التصعيد الميداني بدا منذ الصباح من خلال
استهداف موقع رويسات العلم من خلال
الغارات الاسرائيليه على سياره في بلده
خربه سلم وعلى القرى الحدوديه والقصف
المدفعي وطبعا ننتظر اي بيانات تصدر عن
حزب الله بشان العمليات التي نفذها ربما
في الساعات الماضيه